An upscale mall in Nairobi has turned into a battleground.
[inaudible]
armed men stormed Westgate Mall in the Canyon Capitol just before lunchtime,
firing weapons and throwing grenades.
What appears to witnesses to be at least a dozen gunman have taken hostages
inside. Others have reported that the,
there have been reports. There have been unsubstantiated reports. No, no.
Let me not do those ones. Kenyan police and counter terrorism officers are,
I almost feel like I need to start with the caveat that all these other stories
that we've, you know, gotten to do together, frequent gunfire and, um,
have been me telling you a story. As a journalist, I feel like this story,
it's going to be a story where I'm going to have to stop being a journalist at
some point. Hey, I'm Jetta. Boom, Rod Iron Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab. Oh, check your age. I keep waiting for you to say yes,
but we don't do that. And we don't say anymore.
You just heard that was NPRs east Africa correspondent, Greg Warner,
who's done a bunch of stories with us recently. He came to us with another one.
It was all about a struggle.
He was having trying to figure out how to tell a story.
That is true. I'll just leave it at that.
It's actually a story about the aftermath of an event that um,
probably got more media coverage than almost any event in east Africa last year
and that is the,
the terrorist attack on Westgate Mall in Nairobi. Uh,
this was uh, September 21st, 2013.
It was a kind of Balmy Saturday afternoon Westgate shopping mall crowded with
more than a thousand shoppers.
Even more families than usual were there that day because there was a children's
cooking competition. In fact, the kids were just sitting up their ingredients.
Parents are just taking their seats when, um, shortly after noon
[inaudible] gunman
entered the building shooting AK 47 is going Florida for killing people and the
seats would last for 48.
Hello
now for four days. Essentially I end, you know,
like dozens of international and [inaudible] and local journalists are outside
the mall listening to the sounds of it
done. Fuck.
I'm trying to guess what's happening inside because the press is of course not
allowed in. While this,
while this battle is only going while I'm getting on the air every hour,
sometimes trying to just piece things together. Once they were inside,
they continued to shoot. I'm mentioning a,
there's a plume of tear gas coming my way.
So I'm going to have to try not to cough as I'm answering this, uh,
this question, Gregory move as you need to move.
But my point is that there was no information at the scene other than this
gunfire, what there was, were a whole,
a bunch of survivors.
How do you feel? Great. Help us help.
Yeah. In fact, all the journalists, myself included,
were racing around interviewing eye witnesses. Everybody was, I mean, uh,
everybody was, uh, really running for their lives,
talking to them and also to Kenyan officials to get a picture of what happened.
And the story that emerges from those interviews is basically this,
that the number of terrorists
inside that mall, or at least the beginning,
was 10 to 15 gunmen to between 10 and 15 gunman, 10 to 15 attackers,
up to 15 arms militants with her profile is multiethnic, Kenya,
the United Kingdom, and you know, Arab origin.
This is like a rainbow coalition of Somalis, Kenyans, Arabs,
mostly men, but also including a British woman and a young British woman.
They call the fight widow eye witnesses,
eye witnesses on different floors in the mall, all talking about their gunman,
the people they saw. And it's this multiethnic group. And then of course,
perhaps most alarmingly for the, those of us, you know, living in Nairobi,
there's reports that at least one gunman had after shooting some people thrown
away his gun and actually escape with the fleeing shoppers.
We hear that from a couple of witnesses. So, um,
that's the initial story, but it's not really until eight weeks later,
uh,
in November that u s officials invite about a dozen British and American
journalists into a conference room in the u s embassy.
And we meet in official there from the FBI?
Uh, no,
we had known that the FBI was involved in the postmortem analysis teams from the
United States in Europe joined the investigation.
So this is like a global terrorism events.
So Kenya had invited Scotland Yard and the FBI to figure out who these
terrorists were.
But the FBI had not actually said anything officially in this meeting.
Inside the US embassy was on what's called deep background,
which isn't even off the record. It's, it's a, it's a deeper level of secrecy.
We weren't at that time even allowed to say that a US official head said any of
this stuff. This was just information for us to know. Since then, uh,
I can talk about this meeting because everything that was revealed there has now
become a part of the public record. In fact,
the FBI's has come out publicly and said all these things,
but at the time this was new
and what the FBI, uh,
person said at the time was that his team had access to all the closed circuit
camera footage. Remember, this is, this is a mall. It's a modern mall.
So there's cameras everywhere.
He's seen it from the beginning to the end of the attack from all those
different perspectives and that according to that footage,
everything that we had reported in those first few days was wrong.
Wrong. Ron, in what way?
For instance, 10 to 15 terrorists? No, there weren't 10 to 15 terrorists.
There were four, four. They also said, okay, you've been reporting this a,
this multiethnic coalition of Arabs,
Kenyans and Somalis that so many eyewitnesses told, you know,
they're all Somalis, they're all Somalia, ethnicity, all four of them.
And there was also no evidence than any of the gunman escaped.
I'm just curious from his perspective with where's he trying to, I don't know.
What was your read on this meeting? I actually felt,
and I know other people in that room felt a huge sense of relief because you
know, here we are all are trying to do the work of journalism, you know,
trying to get credible testimony and suddenly here's a guy saying,
okay, take away all that speculation, all those contradictory stories,
all those different reports. Here's some objective evidence.
You can't see this state because it's secret for various antiterrorism reasons,
but this is solid.
And after that time details tonight about the man,
everybody was reporting the same thing.
Unreleased surveillance video shows for arm to Salem only for terrorists,
for terrorist cameras show for arm to sales force suspects are believed to be
from Somali or all Somalis will confirm that all four were killed and none
escaped. The attack is on our debt.
So it kind of put a cap on all those conspiracy theories and speculations that
we're really filling the media. You weren't the slightest bit curious about why,
what might've been left out? Well, I mean, what I guess I really felt was, um,
was sort of empty.
Okay.
You know,
I'm not only a reporter in Nairobi or I'm also a person living in Nairobi.
I mean, I mean I live here, you know, I go to dinner parties,
I take my kid to birthday parties and you know,
I remember especially then in the first months after west gate or so many people
in that mall, invariably somebody would be there at the party.
You had their own survivors story. And you know, it's one thing to say,
oh well that was all this eyewitness testimony. You know, it's not accurate,
but it's another thing to look into the eyes of somebody who's sitting there
with a paper plate of cake in their hand telling you that the terrorist that
they saw is not the terrorist that they saw on this bit of footage that had been
released and was playing on heavy rotation on Kenyan television.
Did that happen more than once? It was, yeah,
and it happened much more than once. I mean, you want me to use your own,
your first name and say Pony my nickname. I'll give you an example.
My friend pruny former neighbor of mine in Nairobi that Saturday morning she
went into the West Gate Mall to get present for her friend's daughter.
I think it was a puzzle, a little puzzle for a four year old girl.
And I'm standing there, I'm just about to pay. And then, Ooh,
explosion automatic weapons. [inaudible] you know, there were shooting,
you could hear the, the grenades and like she says, she ran out of the store,
passing a bunch of chairs and tables that have been set up,
that cooking competition. I didn't have much time to think.
I just ducked under one of those tables. And then it got quite
okay.
You could hear people praying, muttering prayers. Um,
she said she heard a man gasping for breath and she says at one point another
woman was under the table with her.
Her and I would literally get squeezed together. She was pregnant.
She was pregnant. Yeah. And that's the first thing she said. She was like,
I'm pregnant and I'm shot. I didn't have the presence of mind to help her.
She basically took one of those drapes and wrapped it around.
Um, I'd like to stop the bleeding later on. I mean,
cause we were there for quite some time. She said to me, I'm dying.
And um, yeah, at that point I was stroking her hair saying, no, you're not.
You're fine. It's just your leg is just your leg.
And 20 says that while she was under that table,
she would try to peek up through the cloth and for the longest time I couldn't
see anything. Finally, I see, I see the guys
[inaudible]
too. There was two young boys, cute little young innocent looking boys,
you know? Yeah.
It's hard to match and you can't reconcile what they're doing with how they
look. One of them was was kind of, I don't know,
maybe a 1718 year old kid and cute. I mean he's just,
I could just see him as being the son of one of my friends.
This particular one who was closest to us was wearing a red tee shirt and here's
where you get to a small but significant discrepancy that still haunts spooning.
She says she is sure that the two guys she saw and they're just a few feet away
from her,
were wearing short sleeve shirts and afterwards keep seeing these images of four
guys, none of whom are wearing short sleeve. I mean at the beginning,
if you remember, they were saying they were 15 guys,
so then it kind of made sense that,
well the two guys that I saw were different from the four that we're seeing on
TV. But then when people like me started to report that there were only four
categorically only four guys, then I started to say, wait, wait a minute.
I saw their arms. I know I saw short sleeve tee shirts.
You know, it just does not make sense. Nothing adds up. You start to think,
am I crazy? Uh, is my mind playing tricks on me?
I think I saw one thing and then I didn't, but I'm quite sure I saw this.
I mean every day,
every moment of the day you're thinking about what happened,
what happened that day, you know, at these parties out here,
all of these stories like Bruni's the wort, the official narrative,
and yet they felt real. All the details seemed weird enough to be true,
surreal enough to be true. You know, another person was talking about, yeah,
if his powerful story where with the this man was shooting and then he got a
phone call and stopped shooting long enough to answer the phone and then hang up
and start shooting again.
I mean it's like you don't make details like that up and this is what I think
made things so awkward at those conversations because they knew the terrorist
they saw was different then on the video and what that left them with.
Two things.
One is that that I might think that they were lying and two,
that the terrorist that haunts them is still out there.
He know that guy could just be around
[inaudible].
He could see me again. Yeah,
and here's where things get a little weird. Okay, so this is four months later.
Definitely. The news cycle is kind of moved on as a journalist.
I don't really have to report on Westgate anymore. At Saturday afternoon, again,
I'm actually just at home with my kid and
I get a phone call
to call.
That kind of up ended the whole story for him and that's after the break.
This is Darlene calling from Kampala. Uganda.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwsloan.org
this is Julia calling from San Francisco, California.
Radiolab is supported by gunpowder and sky's new film,
heartbeat loud starring Nick Offerman and Kiersey Clemons,
heartbeat loud tells the story of a father and daughter songwriting duo that
become an overnight success selected as the closing night film at the 2018
Sundance Film Festival and costarring Ted Dancing, Sasha Lane,
Blake Tanner, and Toni Collette hearts.
Pete loud opens in select cities starting June 8th
okay.
Radiolab is supported by swell investing and impact investing platform.
What have you got invest in our planet while also investing in your financial
future? Think about that. Our resources are diminishing.
Our population is growing.
Companies solving today's biggest challenges will beat tomorrow's leaders.
Swell helps you invest in high growth companies working towards clean water when
usable energy and green technology.
It's a market opportunity you can feel good about.
Get a $50 bonus when you open your account at swell. investing.com/ [inaudible]
Radiolab
from WM.
YC studios comes the untold story of one of the most aspirational and delusional
teams in sports history.
We knew that we could beat anybody in the world.
I'm doing everything I should be doing and it's still not working sucks.
What do you guys complain about?
You guys are the ones that freaking caused this whole thing. American fiasco.
One team's insane journey to the 1998 World Cup hosted by me.
Roger Bennett had men in Blazers available wherever you get your podcasts,
a bad world cup is better than their work up. You Bet your ass.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and we'll get back to Greg, uh,
reporter Greg Warner's story of the aftermath of the West Gate,
a terror attack in Nairobi, Kenya. You just heard the beginning.
We're not going to tell you the end if there is an end. Yeah,
and we'll pick things up with, uh, Greg getting a phone call.
I get a phone call from a guy who we haven't met yet. The guy named Faruq.
Now a Faruq is not his real name.
He asked Greg to change his name for the story.
It'll become clear why and a bit later and they'll for roots.
Can you go further up please, please.
Cause we're right in the line group is one of the first people I met in the
parking lot on that first day of the attack. Anybody who was a, I mean,
I just had gunfire, gunshots, and I was just, uh, everybody was running away.
It was when I met him. He was actually trying to reach his fiance.
She's stuck in them. Still in there. She's not picking the phone.
I've even written in the message. I don't mess it up. I'm okay. How are you?
She's not just bonded yet. Even I lost my specs,
lost his eyeglasses as he was fleeing. So, oh, let me see if you want,
what name are you looking for? Right to read it.
You hadn't gotten a text from her at messages? No reply. Then, uh, uh,
I called her no replay. What happened? What do I have to switch?
Which she killed.
Oh yeah. She was later found among the, uh, bodies at the morgue and Oh gosh.
But then a week later I met back up with Farrukh and he told me some things that
he had not told me that morning
from first floor, everybody was going to second floor.
There was this moment in the mall,
utter panic where a bunch of people were running up the escalator and one of the
terrorists came down the opposite way down the escalator,
and this guy was pushing everybody down the trucking's somehow for, he says,
you got spun around in the opposite direction of the crowd, and then I saw him.
He gets a good look at this guy. I saw the person very, very clearly.
This person, he was an Arab guy. He says he's sure of it. Yes.
And then he says that he ran and found a hiding spot and after some time he
pokes his head out and he saw him again.
When I told this guy you were standing his clothes,
he had clothes on him. No, but he removed those clothes.
Then he was wearing another clocks inside another platoon site. Basically.
He says that after that first part of the siege, the guy changed his clothes,
dropped his gun, and then insinuated himself into the crowd. And, uh,
when we came out, this guy joined us, he joined us.
So when I saw him outside and I was telling everybody, he's one of them,
he was one of them, but everybody was in shock. Nobody could, uh,
see what I'm saying. And, and do you know what happened to him? No,
I don't know. No idea.
Okay. So back to that phone call in that I was telling you about
[inaudible] Farouk, he calls me out of the blue. He says, Hey,
I'm sitting at a bar at a place called Diamond Plaza,
which is interesting because diamond plaza happens to be one of the prospective
terrorist targets in Nairobi, a known terrorist target besides West Cape Mall.
And he says across from him a few tables away is the fifth gunman.
The Guy who got away, oh, I see him. He's at the next table.
And he says, can you come
good? I got this. And you actually went, well,
at first they told him you should just finish your beer and go home.
I actually hung up, but then I thought,
I probably shouldn't blow this guy off if this were happening in the United
States. I could've just said to the guy, look, if you're so sure about this,
why don't you just call nine one one but there is no nine one one and in Kenya.
And so he called me and I basically said to him, well, what do you,
what do you want me to do? And he said, just, but the police know.
And then I did, I,
I called the source that I know in the police department and he called his
people and they say, okay, we're, we're going to be right there.
Where's this location? You know,
they treated it seriously. So I took it seriously.
Plus there was this small but amazing possibility of this being an incredible
scoop. Yeah, okay. This is my point. Basically I figured like, okay,
I'm gonna wait downstairs until the police show up and then, you know,
cops style, I'm going to race up with them.
And sort of be behind the police so I'll be able to witness it,
but I'll be safe. Right. But I get there and the police are like not there yet.
So I'm waiting downstairs at this bar for weeks calling me like,
where are you man? And I said, well I'm downstairs. And he's like
lucky come up. Oh, he's dead.
I don't think I should go upstairs. Oh Mom. I'm like,
I don't think this is a good idea. Fit on here. No, come on.
And as I'm sitting there arguing with him, he says,
we have to hurry because I've invited this guy, this,
but suppose a terrorists to sit with me at my table.
What you gave him sit with me when he told him to Sydney.
Yeah.
I guess the guy was about to leave and Faruq didn't want him to leave so he
jumped up and somehow convinced this guy,
this stranger does fit, have a drink with him at the table
and he's really scared. Hold on,
let me go get, man, I think it's going to alert.
Nice. Okay. Even those. Yes. Let's go. We'll come.
You are a friend of mine. Yeah, no, no.
So I come
up, I walk into this bar past the pool table, you know,
to this out outdoor bar we bring to the table. And this is Yemen or
from Yemen? Yeah. Yeah. There's this Guy English knows Whaley
late twenties,
uh, fairly slender. He was wearing a tee shirt, black jeans.
One odd detail that stood out to me was that he was wearing two watches. Really?
What are you taking? That's Oscar.
So I sit down, order a beer,
make up this terribly lame story about why I'm there. I'm going all right.
I would just getting a phone case from my wife.
We used to talk to the guy. Yeah. Well the guy didn't speak English,
so you're like Nairobi
[inaudible] I did try to engage this guy in conversation.
He didn't really understand what I was saying except for very basic stuff.
But within a few minutes of my sitting down, the police finally arrived.
Oh Mom. Yeah. This is on the ultrasound.
This is the ocs for you Gregory.
Right away. Faruq jumps up. Ids,
the guy who is completely confused about what's going on.
[inaudible] he was at the mall the day of the attack,
the way I told, you know, my wife got three bullets. Yeah.
And so the police start to question the guy [inaudible] and the interaction is,
is, is very suspicious. They ask him where he's from. He says Nairobi,
even though he had told us that he's from Yemen,
and then they ask him for a passport and then he says, oh,
I don't have my passport. But then he does something, he says, Oh,
I'm from Yemen. So anyway, so that's enough for the police. They,
they put the rubber handcuffs on him and they take him away.
Well, how did the Guy React? He didn't, he seemed kind of, oh, he seems high.
Actually. It's something I hadn't mentioned was that the guy had been chewing,
uh, a narcotic leaf. It's called neuron or cot.
And so he, he seemed, you know,
like a scared high person, you know, or you're scared,
but you're kind of numb to whatever, everything that's happening.
It all seems like a dream. I mean this,
this is like very conjectural but what was not conjectural was that as the
police were leading him out for Rukh just loses.
Huh? You wanna look [inaudible]
he says you kill my wife,
your mother. He starts cursing at the guy, you know,
and then he starts just shouting so that anyone at the bar right here,
here [inaudible] shooting him. Huh? He's the one like,
it's all we could do to kind of calm him down.
They mentioned something four months back in day,
you know my family saying a whooping life in Paris.
I said, I know. Never life. I lost my life.
I saw a man manuals was watching me. You short my love man.
How can I let it go?
This is the day under 10%
[inaudible] that's when the call to prayer comes out of the speakers from a
nearby mountain is the one and for Rick rented all the way through right now.
The Bay then left directly from the [inaudible]
bar to go to the police station to give a statement. And I,
I felt really bad actually.
[inaudible]
I never felt like I was doing something wrong per se,
but I felt that harm had come to this person.
And actually at that point I didn't feel that he was a terrorist.
And I just hoped that the system to which I had helped commit him,
would treat him fairly.
After that, I kept calling the police station, um, every few days,
about 10 days later I found out the guy was released and he hadn't been charged
with anything. And at that point I was like, all right, great.
It all worked out fine for guy was in the wrong place,
the wrong time and you know, got falsely ID possibly. But look,
everything is done.
Everything kind of worked out the way it was supposed to and that's what I
assumed, you know, for, for months basically.
And kind of like went off to do other kinds of reporting, other stories.
But a few months later
I was talking to that police source again and I happened to mention,
we were talking about a different story. I said, yeah,
whatever happened to that. Um, did that guy from Yemen,
that fellow that was picked up at Diamond Plaza and he said, Oh, you know,
it's funny that the witness that you told us about, he never showed up.
He didn't show up. You didn't show up.
They called him for three consecutive days. I never saw it. I said, what for?
Ruth never showed up to give his testimony. Like you can hear from the table.
One thing the bait get so clear on anyone is that he's on his way over to the
police station, full barrels blazing. And so I call Faruq
sorry. No, move on. No.
And his phone is off. And then I called him a week later,
his phone is still off. It's giving this like,
this phone number is no longer in service kind of thing.
So it's actually not until
close to the year anniversary of a Westgate that I get a call.
Okay.
Yeah. Are you okay?
I've been trying your number and it hasn't worked for weeks.
Aw, okay.
And it's Faruq and he's very nervous. He says,
are you alone asking me not to record this conversation?
And he tells me, um, he had gone to the police station just as I suspected,
he marched right over to the police station and they told him, oh, well no,
this is being handled by the antiterrorism police.
So you leave your phone number and the antiterrorism police will give you a
call. A week later
[inaudible]
he started getting calls,
several calls from unknown numbers where people who did not identify themselves,
threatened him, told him not to say anything about this guy.
He had had arrested not to talk to the press
or he'd be sorry and his family would be sorry.
[inaudible]
he was extremely rattled by these phone calls and ultimately actually turned off
his phone. That's why I couldn't get ahold of him.
Had left the country for a short bit,
had come back and was laying very low.
And that's why I'm using an assumed name for him. Well,
I'm not telling his full name because he doesn't want that.
And do you believe the story is about the threats and
I have absolutely no way of knowing for sure. Um, yeah,
that part of his story though seemed the most likely to be true.
The fact that the antiterrorism police, uh,
had called him allegedly and made threats.
That does not sound strange, unfortunately to me. I've,
I've heard that story from lots of very credible people.
Does this make what he saw truer or untrue or we go, I don't know. Suddenly,
suddenly I found myself less willing to discount the story and I was less
comfortable with the official narrative than I want it to be at that point.
So I called up one more guy,
a guy who is not a government official who is not the FBI and yet who had seen
all the video tapes from the mall.
Okay. So can you just give me your name and your, and your title.
My name is Dan Reed.
I'm a producer and director of documentaries most recently terror at the mall,
which was made for HBO and the BBC.
And for that documentary,
Dan got exclusive access to all the surveillance footage inside that mall.
Right. They figured if, if there were more to this story, you could tell me.
So how much footage
did you get? If I can ask again, how many hours or uh, are out?
The footage we obtained added up to about more than 2000 hours. Wow.
And we analyze the timeline where the cameras were and we figured out the
offsets between different cameras. We really did a huge forensic job.
It's mind numbingly tedious to watch a lot of it. But if you do go through it,
you do get the key to a lot of the mysteries of West Gate.
So
like me, he had gone into this project
open minded in some very kind of, you know, sober, sensible people who said,
yeah, there was seven terrorists. I saw seven terrorists. I mean,
you dream of being able to confirm that there was seven gunman.
You dream of being able to confirm that they all escape. What if that were true?
What if we could find evidence, some evidence that that were true,
but in the end he didn't? No. As we,
as we progress further and further with our forensic analysis became harder and
harder to give any credit to some of the wilder pieces of, of eyewitness.
He says, what you see on those tapes is what the FBI said. You'd see four guys,
all Somali, no evidence they escaped.
Exactly was then how does he square the stories you were hearing with the
stories you were reporting?
Well, uh, that part was actually quite interesting. We had a lot of people say,
yeah, there was a woman,
young British woman, they call the fight widow.
And it's interesting because when I was going through this footage,
my wife looked over my shoulder,
pointed to one of the four terrorists on the screen. And at one point you said,
oh, is that a go? And we came to the conclusion that that one of the gunman was,
you know, very slender and he actually does sashay along in,
in what is frankly quite an a feminine way.
And similarly he says,
you can justify some of the reports that one of the gunman was an Arab because
one of them did in fact have lighter skin than your average Somali.
And you can explain that people thought that they were more gunman,
10 or 15 gunman because there were a lot of guys with guns running around
including security guards and later policemen.
There were a lot more policemen than there were gunman.
I did speak with one eye witness who said that,
that that t saw one of the terrorists, excuse me, change clothes and escape.
Well, is it a
no, that doesn't, that doesn't match anything that we saw.
I think the thing that's the question we'll ask your eye witnesses is,
is how do you know this person with a weapon who changed clothes was a
terrorist. It may have been a policeman.
We certainly heard stories of policemen taking off changing clothes or taken off
the and any distinctive clothing. I don't know if those stories were true,
but we, we heard stories [inaudible]
the uniform policemen took off their uniform because they didn't want to fight.
I guess. Yeah, I mean that, but that's pure Greg. That's pure.
I mean there was totally speculation and you did not see that on the,
any of the security. Certainly didn't. I mean, I, I've,
I've just had so many conversations like people saying to me, no, they escaped.
And I'm like, why do you think that escapes? You know,
these guys don't come to escape. If you escape, you failed.
He says, take the 2008 terrorist attack in Mumbai.
They had murdered 35 people at the hotel. This is another film that he made.
There's a moment in that film where one of the gunmen,
one of the last remaining gunman,
the guy is trapped in a hotel room and he is next to,
he's in the bath tub next to his, his comrade who's dad is dying.
He's talking to one of his handlers on the cell phone.
Well, they come from [inaudible].
Dan was able to get a recording of that call.
Hello, hello. [inaudible]
and the, the handlers very calmly say to him, you know, your, your mission
[inaudible]
will not be a success until you are killed. And then they say to him,
yeah, the incident last Salami I beat you,
please leave your phone on, switched on,
leave the line open in your pocket so that we can hear when you go out and are
killed by the enemy security forces.
Hello.
So there is a whole script for this kind of operation and it ends with the death
of the gunman at the hands of the enemy.
Wow. That's how he knows they didn't escape.
He says not just because there's no evidence on the film,
but because it's the last thing they would've wanted. And yet
it's, I mean I, I the, the, these, the rumors that the terrorist escape,
the rumors that there was a woman amongst them,
the rumors that they got changed, the rumors, they don't seem to go away.
Even when confronted by quite solid evidence.
It's almost as if the facts don't matter.
[inaudible]
so I called Farrukh. He's still sticking to his story.
He says he saw it. He saw though he's really too nervous to go on tape.
But I did run it by puny my former neighbor in a rugby who's 100% still pretty
sure that the guy she saw in the mall hasn't been accounted for,
I think I'm sure about it. But
what if the government said, here's the bodies, here's the DNA evidence,
here's the four. They dog died, they died in the second day or third day,
whatever it was. This is how they died and here's the DNA proof.
You know what would really make me happy is if they even ask the questions,
be it the media, be it the government. Why did we go from 15 to four?
Yeah.
So I told her quickly tell you how we arrived at four cause I told her about the
meeting with the FBI and how we got this information.
Then I told her about Dan Reed watching 2000 hours of videotape and I told her
about how I investigated for Rukh story and mostly came up empty.
I told her not just everything that I know all these facts,
but how I got to them.
Because in the end maybe the facts aren't enough.
The facts need to make sense, especially for people who were there.
But I can imagine for anybody who was not there, anybody who's reading it. Yep.
The evidence says, and then you move on.
You're listening to you. I feel like I'm,
I'm learning much more about my job and being a journalist and maybe it's not so
pretty because I feel like, uh,
that day coming out of that meeting with the FBI and feeling like,
okay,
now we have some solid evidence that can be reported and we can move on.
Uh, felt good. I mean, it felt like offering,
instead of offering shaky s as testimony,
we could offer truth at least as best we could understand it,
but it feels like maybe that was too sudden and too
to an inquisitive in a way to match the emotions that were still in the air and
wrote me at that time. Maybe it felt like abandonment,
even though it was meant to feel like clarity for me.
It still, there's a little
glimmer of maybe that's not the full story. I, I,
I'm inclined to believe that there were four,
but then it's like what I saw does not make sense and that I'll never be able to
really reconcile and I just kind of have to leave it at that.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
a lot of people to thank for the story. Of course, Greg Warner,
first and foremost, NPRs East Africa correspondent, and also,
thanks very much to Jason [inaudible], USO Blogger, Robert ally, Heidi vote,
NPR international editor, Didi Skanky and senior international editor,
Edith Chapman for allowing us to borrow Greg on our show. I'm Jeb and Ron.
I remembered Krulwich thanks for listening.